ازاله المواد الصلبه العالقه من مياه
البحر وتحويلها الى مياه نقيه ونظيفه
صالحه للشرب احد الحلول التي يعتمد عليها
كثير من الناس حول العالم لتلبيه الطلب
المتزايد على المياه لكن انجاز محطات
لتحليه مياه البحر يتطلب استخداما كثيفا
للطاقه شركه وتراي ومقرها النورج قالت
انها توصلت الى حل عمليه الترشيح بالتناضح
العكسي الموفره
للطاقه ماذا تفعل وتراس حسنا نحن نجمع بين
عالمين من التكنولوجيا التقنيه الحاليه في
عالم جديد ونفكر في طريقه اكثر ذكاء
لتحليه المياه بالتناضح
العكسي تشرف شركه وتر رايس على محطه
لتحليه مياه البحر على ساحل النرويج
باستخدام التناضح العكسي وهي عمليه يتم
فيها دفع الماء عبر اغشيه دقيقه لفصل
الملح يتطلب ذلك كميات كبيره من الطاقه
لكن ما يميز طريقه وتر رايز هو ان الماء
يسحب من اعماق البحر تقول الشركه ان
تقنيتها تستخدم بعد ذلك طريقه الضغط
بتوازن السوائل او ما يعرف علميا بهي
دروست تيكا وهو ضغط الماء الذي يرتفع كلما
تعمقت لتوصيل مياه البحر الى الارض ما
يقلل من استهلاك
الطاقه لاننا نذهب تحت سطح البحر ونستخدم
الضغط
الهيدروستاتيكي ووزن الماء فوقنا فاننا
قادرون على توفير الطاقه ونوفر ما بين 30
و4 في تقع معظم مشاريع تحليه المياه ذات
القدره العاليه في العالم في منطقه الشرق
الاوسط حيث الطاقه ارخص والقوانين البيئيه
اقل صرامه من البلدان الاخرى تقول وتر
رايز ان تقنيتها تقلل الحاجه الى الاراضي
الساحليه بنسبه تصل الى 90% مما يؤدي الى
انخفاض انبعاثات ثاني اكسيد الكربون تنتج
وحدتها القياسيه 50 مليون لتر من المياه
العذبه يوميا
ما يكفي لتزويد مدينه بماء الشرب يراوح
عدد سكانها بين 300 و400 ال نسمه يقول
خبراء ان التلوث المتصاعد وحالات الجفاف
غير المسبوقه وتقلص طبقات المياه الجوفيه
ليست سوى بعض من الاسباب التي تؤدي الى
تاجيج ازمه المياه العالميه وتكثيف البحث
عن حلول ناجعه في مجال تحليه مياه البحر
l